and finally new rule it's time to change
the symbol of the Republican Party from
this to this because that's all they are
now trolls
people who get off on provoking other
people who are trying to have an adult
conversation Americans keep wondering
why is it that all this White House
seems to do is pick childish fights when
we have so many big problems why is
Trump still attacking Hillary she's not
an office all you have to do Drive her
out of the woods Republicans at seven
years to come up with the health care
plan why don't they have one Oh
snowflakes trolls don't have health care
plans they write lazy Lube moochers what
health care try getting a job that is
their health care plan because they're
not well if the other side is shedding
liberal tears it doesn't matter if you
crash the health insurance market or the
prisons overflow or Putin takes Italy
look at all those snowflakes whining we
did that Dwight Trump made scott pruett
the EPA's biggest critic head of the EPA
Republicans used to be against lead in
the drinking water now they're happy to
poison their children if it'll make al
gore sad why does Trump love coal same
reason there are people out there now
intentionally modifying their trucks to
produce more air pollution Republicans
aren't an opposition party now they're
the Democrats crazy ex-girlfriend
[Laughter]
and job one job only is to make liberals
freak like carrying assault rifles into
a restaurant or a snowball into Congress
or suddenly tweeting for no reason that
transgender people are now banned from
the military you think Trump cares who
serves in our military as long as it's
not him he's good people say why does
Trump tweet so much those tweets are a
distraction
no the tweets are the whole point
governing is the distraction you
remember this picture Trump right after
he fired Comey welcoming the Russian spy
master into the Oval Office to give our
Intel to him a move that left most
people stunned but not his people their
reaction wasn't oMG what a traitor
it was lol what a troll puppet you're
the puppet anytime you see that
shit-eating grin you know it's troll
time here it is again a couple of months
ago when Trump invited to the White
House the axis of stupid
[Laughter]
Kid Rock Ted Nugent and Sarah Palin the
Denarius stillborn of the House of
Pancakes and Sarah Palin perfectly
defined her party's transformation that
day when she said of liberals it's
really funny to me to see their splode e
heads keeps gloating Sarah slowed and
just like your meth lab ten years ago
trolls weren't even a thing or if they
were we at a different word sadist now
they run the country and by run it I
mean can't and won't